et notre invité ce matin c'est Laurent
Fabius bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ou on est ravi de vous
recevoir président du Conseil
constitutionnel on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour
la nuit du droit manifestation dans
plusieurs villes de France que vous avez
lancé en 2017 l'objectif c'est de mieux
faire connaître la justice le droit
pourquoi c'est nécessaire
parce que le droit est présent dans tous
les secteurs de notre vie quand vous
louez un appartement vous passez un
contrat quand vous êtes recruté par une
entreprise il y a des dispositions
juridiques le droit est partout et il
est assez mal connu et donc c'est pour
ça que quand je suis arrivé à la
présidente du conseil consuel j'ai lancé
cette nuit du droit qui a lieu partout
en France on me disait qu'il y a plus de
150 manifestations diverses alors ça
prend des formes tout à fait différentes
ça peut être
des conférences des procès fictifs des
films etc j'avais fait ça déjà quand je
dirigeais notre diplomatie j'avais lancé
la nuit des idées
c'est à dire partout dans le monde il y
avait une soirée consacrée une nuit
consacrée au débat d'idées vous avez
remarqué que la nuit il se passe pas mal
de choses mais en particulier il y a une
qualité d'attention qui est particulière
donc là ce soit il y a partout en France
métropole et outre-mer donc ces
manifestations et aux conseils
constitutionnel il y a une manifestation
particulière autour du thème de la
guerre et du droit et justement ce thème
que vous avez choisi dans le contexte de
la guerre en Ukraine évidemment est-ce
que vous pensez qu'une nouvelle ère du
droit pourrait s'ouvrir après cette
guerre en Ukraine
mais bon d'abord il faut arriver à
arrêter la guerre à négocier à trouver
une paix qui soit juste et puis il faut
tirer les leçons oui je le souhaite
comme vous bien sûr mais enfin on voilà
dans l'immédiat évidemment il faut être
au soutien des
Ukrainiens et la soirée et la nuit du
droit au Conseil
j'ai la chance d'avoir pu faire venir
des personnalités tout à fait
remarquables le procureur près de la
cour internationale donc c'est la
juridiction qui s'occupe de tous les
crimes de guerre etc le procureur
général du crâne donc il est vraiment au
cœur du sujet
Robert Badinter une pianiste
internationale qui est très engagée
et puis un colonel français qui vous
savez a creusé dans les fosses pour
identifier les victimes donc toutes ces
personnes vont nous expliquer à quel
point la guerre et le droit enfin le
droit ne s'arrête pas pendant la guerre
mais évidemment il faut refuser
l'impunité de tous ceux qui ont comme il
écrit ou de tous ceux qui les ont
ordonnés vous vous diffuserez ce soir un
message enregistré du président
zellinski est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
sur quoi il mange je n'ai pas encore
l'ambassade nous a annoncé que la
journée j'avais demandé au présidentiel
inscrit
d'avoir la gentillesse de nous faire
parvenir un message et l'ambassade m'a
dit que le message est allé est
enregistré aujourd'hui mais c'est
intéressant dès lors que c'est le cas
parce que
bon il s'adressera bien sûr aux
participants à la ligne droite mais
au-delà à l'opinion publique française
et internationale et
je pense que ce sera intéressant
justement parce que vous nous parlez de
ce colonel qui sera présent et qui a
creusé dans les faux son parle de crimes
de guerre aujourd'hui en Russie comment
on enquête en temps de guerre comment on
est sûr que la justice ne se mêle pas
aux politiques et réciproquement
le problème c'est pas tellement le
mélange entre la Suisse et la politique
le problème c'est
d'abord de recueillir les preuves vous
avez raison parce qu'il faut le faire
tout de suite après ça disparaît et donc
la France est au côté des Ukrainiens
professeurs ensuite il y a des instances
juridiques à introduire alors tout un
débat cours pénal international
juridiction nationale juridiction
internationale Haddock je n'entre pas
là-dedans et puis une fois que
les les jugements ont eu lieu il faut
les faire exécuter et donc il faut aller
chercher alors chercher je dirais le le
la personne qui a qui est un exécutant
c'est déjà difficile mais on peut le
faire mais le problème ce sont les chefs
et pour aller chercher Vladimir Poutine
c'est ça la question c'est toute une
discussion les les spécialistes disent
que tant qu'il est au pouvoir c'est très
difficile et même si il y a des
jugements qui
de condamne ça veut dire qu'il ne pourra
pas sortir de de son pays mais l'idéal
si je puis dire serait si les jugé et
condamné de pouvoir faire exécuter ses
jugements vous pensez qu'il sera jugé un
jour vous dites il refuser l'impunité
est-ce que vous pensez que
oui je pense que oui pourquoi est-ce
qu'il faut refuser l'infidélité d'abord
pour les victimes et puis pour la paix
future parce que quand vous y
réfléchissez ce sera des thèmes de de la
réunion de ce soir
il n'y a pas de paix sans justice la
justice et la condition de la paix
future et donc pour toutes ces raisons
il faut aller chercher les exécutants et
ceux qui ont donné les arbres j'imagine
que vous allez vous pencher aussi sur la
question des référendums qui ont été
organisés en
Ukraine et référendum organisé par les
Russes qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que au
regard du droit international qu'est-ce
que c'est ces référendum peuvent avoir
comme valeur ils sont totalement
illégaux et non strictement avec une
valeur d'ailleurs mis à part je ne sais
pas un pays peut-être la Syrie ou un
autre tous les pays la Corée du Nord
voilà
tous les pays le refusent
et aucune valeur juridique mais mais bon
j'étais ministre des Affaires étrangères
donc même si aujourd'hui je fais autre
chose je réfléchis un petit peu sur ces
sujets
l'une des questions c'est qu'à partir du
moment où juridiquement
c'est oblast sont intégrés dans le
territoire russe d'une part ça rend
difficile ensuite compte jusqu'à la
condition de rendre à l'Ukraine c'est
territoires et d'autre part on comprend
bien un peu militaire qu'une attaque
contre ces oblast devenu heureuse
pourrait-elle considéré comme une
attaque contre la Russie donc
juridiquement la menace de guerre
nucléaire juridiquement
j'allais dire d'une formule qui à la
fois juridique et compréhensible c'est
nul
mais dans le débat ça a une certaine
importance vous qui avez connu Vladimir
Poutine quand vous étiez au Quai d'Orsay
vous dites qu'il ne comprend que le
rapport de force on peut encore discuter
pour vous la discussion est fort
possible
les guerres se finissent par des
négociations
bon mais
je discuterai pas avec la Russie tant
que Vladimir Poutine qui en est le
président vous êtes d'accord
il y a d'abord l'aspect militaire et la
France comme beaucoup d'autres pays
avant même la question juridique aide
sur le plan économique et les sanctions
et d'autre part sur le plan des moyens
militaires bon mais à un moment ou un
autre il faut bien être enfin ça fasse
dans son dernier livre François Hollande
explique que en fait Vladimir Poutine
portait le germe de cette guerre depuis
depuis 10 ans en fait depuis 2012 vous
qui l'avez connu par le passé est-ce que
oui François Hollande dans son livre
parle de la politique étrangère c'est
moi qui était comment si je puis dire
sous son sa présidence et effectivement
on a vu monter tout cela et ça s'est
développé beaucoup mais la bascule enfin
ce serait une longue discussion
je l'ai vu se rejoint ce que dit
Hollande dans son livre au moment vous
rappelez peut-être ou les États-Unis et
nous-mêmes avions décidé de d'intervenir
en Syrie parce que le dictateur local
Bachar el-Assad avait utilisé des qui
sont inadmissibles et donc il y avait un
plan qui était concerné par les
Américains etc au dernier moment le
président Obama a dit bon utilisant tel
ou tel projet je n'y vais pas et j'ai vu
alors vu le champs Poutine bon qui est
un homme bon qui qui
beaucoup de défauts mais qui comprend ce
qui se passe a dit finalement les
États-Unis et première puissance du
monde ne veulent pas intervenir dans
cette partie du monde et immédiatement
après il y avait un G20 comme on dit à
Saint-Pétersbourg ou concrètement on a
vu la bascule s'opérer et à partir de ce
moment-là vous avez toute une série
d'opérations notamment la Crimée etc bon
donc
c'est cette cette stratégie du rapport
de force et et Poutine est en train de
faire en Ukraine ce qu'il a commencé à
faire dans d'autres territoires
on va parler de l'actualité du Conseil
constitutionnel un autre actualité il y
a quelques jours vous étiez à Marseille
pour rencontrer des
retourner pour rencontrer des lycéens
alors expliquez-nous quel est le but de
ces déplacements justement à la
rencontre de la semaine en fait j'ai été
avec le collège du conseil nous sommes
neufs parce que nous avons décidé de
délocaliser un certain de nos audiences
bon
évidemment nous sions à Paris le plus
souvent mais on vient une fois par
trimestre nous allons en région et nous
tenons une audience comme nous le
faisons à Paris et nous l'avons fait
cette fois-ci à Marseille alors nous
prenons nous examinons deux questions ce
qu'on appelle les fameuses QPC devant
les magistrats les juges voilà et la
population et la semaine suivante je
reviens alors là en l'occurence à
Marseille pour expliquer devant la fac
de droits les étudiants et les
professeurs ce que nous avons décidé
pourquoi nous l'avons décidé donc
vraiment c'est sur le terrain nous en
avons profité supplément cette fois-ci
pour que chacune et chacun d'entre nous
nous allions dans un lycée pour faire ce
qu'on appelait le montant à une heure
d'instruction civique discuter avec les
professeurs et les élèves les lycéens ça
fait partie du fait qu'il y a une
méconnaissance du droit chez les
Français oui enfin les Français comme
d'autres d'ailleurs ne sont pas des
spécialistes de droit mais si vous
voulez le droit c'est d'abord mon droit
et puis c'est l'arc Boutant de la
société alors comme le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est le garant de
l'État de droit en France il est évident
que ces déplacements avec leur but
pédagogique sont utiles et en général
grâce à la presse ils sont très
largement diffusés et appréciés ces
déplacements vous les faites depuis
longtemps mais en général vous allez
voir un public ce que vous venez de dire
des étudiants qui connaissent bien le
droit qui savent de quoi on parle là
quand vous allez voir des gens alors
grâce à la presse et puis bon parce que
il y a la télévision locale parce qu'il
y a la presse locale et bon c'est
toujours un problème c'est d'ailleurs le
grand public bon mais alors là on a
d'autres moyens qui sont notre site
internet ces réunions la nuit du droit
mais il y a des efforts de pédagogie à
faire vous êtes tout à fait raison mais
justement face à ce grand public des
gens moins spécialisés est-ce que vous
êtes surpris par certaines questions
est-ce que vous êtes désarçonné par
certaines postures ou globalement vous
sentez que le il y a une appétence pour
ces questions et que les gens voient à
peu près de quoi on parle à peu près oui
mais quand non mais bon les gens ne sont
pas spécialistes c'est normal mais moi
j'essaie toujours de prendre des
exemples concrets et de tirer le fil à
partir du moment où vous tirez le fil
les gens disent ah oui oui et donc
qu'il soit d'ailleurs jeune moyen vieux
le droit intéresse pas quand il est
abstrait mais quand concrètement dit ben
voilà vis-à-vis de mon contrat
d'électricité vis-à-vis de mes droits
vis-à-vis de mes devoirs etc qu'est-ce
que je dois faire ça c'est intéressant
vous le dites le Conseil fonctionnel et
le garant de l'État de droit on voit
apparaître aujourd'hui dans le débat la
question de ces cellules internes au
sein des parties pour lutter contre les
violences sexuelles et sexy alors sont
vraiment de règles très claires très
transparente est-ce que ça ça vous
inquiète sur l'état c'est très compliqué
comme problème parce que vous y
réfléchissez j'en suis sûr comme
journaliste ça vous concerne évidemment
aussi à ce titre vous avez trois
principes qui sont qui sont également
respectables mais qu'ils ont très
difficiles à concilier premier principe
il faut lutter contre les atteintes
sexistes et sexuelles bon ça c'est
fondamental bon ça c'est deuxième
principe la justice est rendue par les
juges c'est pas rendu par comme ça sur
le coin du café troisième principe le
soit appel la présomption d'innocence
qui est très difficile en plus à
respecter quand il s'agit de
personnalité médiatique bon et quand
vous mettez tout ça ensemble évidemment
comment se fait la conciliation bon ça
aboutit à ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
mais le problème de fond il est là
une forme de justice politique qui se
substitue à la justice tout court pour
vous
oui alors il y a tout ce débat est-ce
qu'il y a une politisation de la justice
ou une judiciarisation de la politique
en tout cas la difficulté quand on
creuse vraiment le sujet c'est la
conciliation de ces trois principes et
évidemment aujourd'hui vous voyez les
embarder qui existent
il y a aussi l'émergence des réseaux
sociaux qui se sont une espèce de
tribunal populaire incontrôlable et
incontrôlée est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a
pas est-ce qu'il faudrait pas réguler
aussi si vous êtes d'accord je vous
renvoie alors c'est un peu austère mais
il y a un rapport qui vient de sortir du
Conseil d'État sur les réseaux sociaux
qui est tout à fait remarquable que j'ai
lu il y a quelques jours qui explique
alors l'ampleur du problème que nous
vivons et puis les pistes vers
lesquelles il faudrait aller pour
essayer de régler tout ça alors c'est
d'autant plus compliqué que souvent
c'est une dimension internationale et
que évidemment on peut faire des choses
dans une certaine mesure sur le plan
national mais c'est beaucoup plus
difficile sur le plan aujourd'hui sur
l'état de droit en France
écoutez il y a quelques années je ne le
pensais pas mais quand vous je vais pas
rentrer dans la politique puisque je
peux plus de politique mais quand vous
entendez le discours
tenu par les uns et par certains sur le
thème waouh
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ce qui compte
c'est uniquement ce que décide le peuple
le droit c'est un empêcheur de tourner
en rond
souvent je je me réfère à cette phrase
que je trouve extrêmement profonde et
courte de Victor Hugo souvent la foule
trahit le peuple
je pense qu'il avait tout compris Victor
cette plus petite vous l'avez dit mais
quand même Eric Dupond-Moretti
aujourd'hui c'est un garde des sceaux
pour la première fois qui a envoyé
devant la Cour de Justice de la
République est-ce que pour vous c'est
gênant
mettez-vous un instant à ma place de
président du Conseil constitutionnel je
reconnais que c'est une suggestion des
raisonnable je ne pense pas que je dois
faire des commentaires sur ce sujet on
va parler d'un autre sujet on va passer
au texte examiné par le Parlement en ce
moment Emmanuel Macron le président de
la République pense qu'il faut repousser
l'âge de départ à la retraite et pour
équilibrer le système mais aussi pour
financer l'éducation la transition
écologique il l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises est-ce que est-ce que ça c'est
constitutionnellement c'est possible
est-ce qu'on peut prendre l'argent des
retraites pour financer autre chose que
les retraites d'un point de vue purement
constitutionnel mais comme nous vous
allez à nous risquons d'être saisis de
ces sujets
je ne veux pas vous faire la réponse
avant d'être saisie d'autant que nous
sommes à collège
mais si vous voulez il y a aussi un
principe qui s'appelle que qui dit que
les recettes ne sont pas affectées vous
avez entendu parler de cela bon je vous
parlais plus loin
de l'IVG puisque il va y avoir un texte
au Sénat sur la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG on voit que ce droit est menacé
dans certains pays la Cour suprême des
États-Unis est revenu sur ce droit à
l'avortement Georgia mélony la future
probable future première ministre
italienne veut encadrer plus strictement
son accès à ce que ce droit est en train
de reculer ce que pour vous c'est
important qu'il soit constitutionnalisé
aujourd'hui en France doyen un risque
aussi dans notre pays alors d'abord sur
la Cour suprême américaine qui est enfin
ses décisions récent c'est une grosse
femme qui a beaucoup de prestige mais
elle a pris des décisions vous avez vu
qui ont choqué un certain nombre de
personnes pas seulement aux États-Unis
mais dans le monde pas seulement sur
l'IVG d'ailleurs sur l'environnement bon
pas m'immiscer dans ce qui me regarde
pas mais ça monte si vous voulez sentir
une conclusion en général que lorsqu'on
nomme des juges pour des raisons comment
dire idéologiques et qu'en plus on les
nombres à vie
un certain nombre de conséquences
maintenant sur l'IVG déjà dans les lois
et dans la jurisprudence du Conseil il y
a
une protection tout à fait légitime de
la dignité de la femme des droits de la
femme maintenant j'ai vu qu'il y avait
cette initiative qui tend à aller vers
une
inclusion dans la Constitution nous
verrons si c'est le cas je rappelle ça
c'est déjà eu l'occasion de le dire que
si on veut réviser la Constitution il y
a une procédure qui s'appelle l'article
89 de la Constitution si vous avez
j'imagine que vous vous baladez avec une
Constitution dans votre poche toujours
si vous regardez le chapitre qui va sur
la révision qui s'appelle de la révision
c'est l'article 89 ce n'est pas un autre
parmi les choses qui sont en cours de
l'examen pour lequel le Conseil a été
saisi il y a le l'examen du référendum
d'initiative partagée lancée par la
nuque reçu le 20 septembre la
proposition il y a peu de jours et
nous allons nous avons un mois pour
examiner sa recevabilité concrètement il
faut un certain nombre de parlementaires
et il faut puisqu'il s'agit d'un
référendum que la proposition
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un article et
l'article 11 de la conscience donc nous
allons regarder cela et nous rendrons
notre décision
voilà moi
si nous disons non ce sera terminé si
nous disons OUI à ce moment-là s'ouvre
une nouvelle période où il faut que il y
ait le recueil de pas mal de signatures
et nous contrôlons évidemment et
également cela mais actuellement c'est
la première phase nous examinons et je
vous dis avec un délai d'amoi si c'est
bien conforme à l'article le seuil c'est
10% du corps électoral si je me trompe
pas donc ça fait 4,8 millions de
signataires
non d'ailleurs
la dernière fois il y avait un référence
de Paris sur l'aéroport de Paris et à
l'issue alors ça n'avait pas fonctionné
et à l'issue de ce de cette tentative
nous avons fait un petit rapport bon
évidemment respectueux mais nous avions
dit que
en des termes choisis enfin vous voyez
bien vous voulez en venir que ça nous
paraissait quand même un chiffre élevé
d'ailleurs beaucoup de voix on dit c'est
un chiffre élevé mais le problème c'est
que le chiffre il est prévu par les
textes donc ce sont ces textes là qui
s'appliquent et actuellement c'est 10%,
donc c'est ça fait beaucoup tout le
monde parle du seuil de 1 million vous
pensez que ce serait raisonnable même le
président de la République avait évoqué
ça en disant à mignon ce serait possible
aucune série de
propositions dans l'air de révision mais
vous savez que depuis 2008 après qu'il y
a eu 24 révisions de la Constitution il
y en a plus et contenu des conditions
pour réviser c'est assez complexe mais
effectivement c'est un chiffre qui est
difficile à atteindre juste une dernière
chose sur l'actualité du traitement du
Conseil constitutionnel j'ai vu que vous
aviez eu 99 recours sur législatives et
qu'il en apparemment il en reste 41 qui
sont encore en cours d'instant on a très
rapidement
juger les recours qui étaient
manifestement ils recevable bon et donc
ils nous en reste un certain nombre et
nous allons les examiner les juger entre
maintenant et le premier trimestre de
l'année prochaine parce que il faut
aussi que certains se examinés par la
commission des financements des comptes
de financement des campagnes et nous
nous sommes juste d'appel ça veut dire
que sur 41 cas on pourrait encore avoir
des surprises des décisions par exemple
d'un validation de scrutin ou des choses
comme ça on regarde on regarde quelle
est la situation juridique notre
jurisprudence en gros dit ceci
il faut pour annuler qui est une
irrégularité importante
mais qui est un effet sur les résultats
du scrutin or cette fois-ci
il y a quelques cas où la différence de
voix entre le gagnant et le perdant est
assez faible et donc quand la différence
est assez faible une irrégularité même
minime peut entraîner une annulation
mais je ne sais pas encore examiné donc
je peux pas toutes les manières je vous
dirai cela lorsque le jour où nous
prenons notre décision et donc c'est
entre en ce moment et le premier
trimestre de l'année prochaine
une question sur le Conseil national de
la de la refondation est-ce que est-ce
que quel est votre regard sur cette sur
cette initiative là cette démarche là
est-ce que c'est une bonne façon de
redynamiser la la démocratie la
participation citoyenne ou est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir un risque que cet instance
une fine permet de court-circuter le
Parlement
quand j'ai procédé parce que c'est le
président du conseil qui le fait à
l'investiture du Président de la
République j'ai prononcé un tout petit
discours et j'ai dit ce qui était pas un
scoop d'ailleurs beaucoup disent qu'il y
a un malaise démocratique en France bon
ça il suffit de regarder les résultats
des abstentions etc bon et donc tout à
fait normal que les responsables quel
qu'il soit réfléchissent comment on
pourrait diminuer ce malaise la
démocratie ça peut pas être on vote pour
x ou y euh à l'élection présidentielle
et puis rendez-vous c'est un peu plus
tard tout le monde comprend ça et donc
il y a des recherches parfaitement
légitimes qui sont faites par les uns
par les autres comment rendre vivante la
démocratie alors vous avez eu euh le le
comité qui s'est occupé du climat vous
avez très souvent dans des
localités des référendum locaux sur les
budgets vous avez toute une série de
recherche et si j'ai bien compris ce que
ce conseil fait partie de ces recherches
bon la difficulté c'est que en même
temps nous sommes et ça c'est
fondamental dans une démocratie
parlementaire
là nous sommes à publique Sénat ce sont
les sénateurs et les députés qui votent
la loi et donc il faut à la fois arriver
à obtenir le sentiment de la population
mais au moment où il faut décider ce
sont quand même les parlementaires qui
votent et donc il y a des recherches de
conciliation et j'ai compris que ce
conseil faisait partie de cela voilà
alors nous allons voir comment ça
fonctionne merci l'eau en Fabius merci à
vous merci et pour votre message sur les
végés donc on a compris faudra passer
par l'article 89 c'est le message que
vous avez adoré pour
une vision de la Constitution c'est
l'article 89 et merci d'être venu pour
nous parler donc de la nuit du droit qui
aura lieu on le rappelle dans plus de
150 villes en France pour mieux faire
connaître le droit initiative ce soit du
Conseil constitutionnel c'est bien sûr
ce soir merci beaucoup
et merci Stéphane on passe au club des
territoires
[Musique]